senator bob dole spent his life trying
to make a difference for those he served
he was born robert joseph dole july 22nd
1923 in the small town of russell kansas
the dolls were a modest hard-working
family
as a teenager he was quite competitive
especially when it came to track
in 1942 dole joined the army during
world war ii he was critically injured
it would take him years to get back on
his feet but he never fully recovered
after the war and law school dole became
russell's youngest legislator in 1960 he
was elected to congress and the senate
in 1968 where he served until 1996. dole
had his eyes on the white house and ran
as the vice presidential candidate with
gerald ford on the republican ticket in
1976 the ticket lost
also in the 70s he met and married
elizabeth his second wife who made her
own run for the white house
dole was named gop candidate for
president in 1996 but lost the uphill
battle to incumbent president bill
clinton in 1997 he was awarded the
presidential medal of freedom the
highest civilian award he already had
two purple hearts and a bronze star
in his retirement bob dole was
instrumental in getting the world war ii
memorial built in washington and where
before the pandemic he often spent
weekends greeting his fellow veterans
dan shenaman nbc news